all right ladies and gentlemen let me
introduce you to my 2014 Chevrolet
Silverado work truck and if it weren't
for a work truck I wouldn't be on here
today to show you a tutorial on how to
install key fobs for the truck
as you can see there is no key files
with this truck but that'll change here
today because I got something on the
inside that will be able to program new
key fobs for the truck without bringing
it to a dealer the pricing is only about
50 to 70 dollars for the first fob
second fob could be as low cost as 20 to
30 dollars we got on the left is a
doorman brand remote and then on the
inside a programmer that will allow me
to program this remote to the truck
without having to bring it to the dealer
which will save you a lot of time and
money and then on the right is a
secondary key fob for my second spare
key this truck came with no key fobs and
I figured I'd have them installed with
the price I was able to get these for
and I heard that this programmer is only
good for three or five uses when you're
programming all your remotes at once
it's good for a Sierra Silverado
suburban and Yukon of these years 2014
2015 or 2014 to 2016 Silverado
and 2014 is an odd year with these
trucks because in 2015 is whenever they
switched over the 2500s but in 2014 is
whenever they switched them over to
these more Square looking trucks which I
think has a nice appearance so we're
going to be trying to install these here
today it's the first time this truck has
probably ever had fobs and about eight
years of its existence let's see if this
packaging will open pleasantly I've
always had certain experiences with this
kind of Packaging
one key fob instructions
and programmer
device may cause harmful interference
and this device must accept any
interference received including
interference that may cause undesired
operation as limited number of uses
depending on application see they set
the limited number of uses that way you
have to buy a new one but that does a
lot of E-Waste and I think these are
considered something that could be
recycled at a Best Buy or somewhere that
recycle electronics a lot of E-Waste
they should have make an unlimited uses
or if anyone knows how to make them and
set them to unlimited uses let us know
now if you're looking to go the same
route I would there's the park number on
the top right
99355 disclaimer all currently
programmed and new remotes must be
programmed to vehicle please have all
remotes in hand at the time programming
and I have the door closed and my
seatbelt on to reduce the door chime
whenever I turn the key let's get
started and hopefully try to get it on
the first go that way I don't use one of
the uses on the remote just in case I
want to reprogram other remotes or I
don't get them all programmed in the
first go which has happened a few times
with the other vehicle I had and I lost
some of the uses let's try to get on the
first go I'm going to turn the key to
the on position without starring the
engine that's one turn and then a second
turn
okay
okay that should light up all the gauges
I'm going to turn the radio off
then I got the key programmer here
insert this into the OBD2 port which is
down at the bottom of the truck
should be about right here
what's it do you got it upside down okay
remote key learning active on the dash
press and hold lock and unlock on the
first key fob
[Music]
okay you hear that beep that's the first
one second fob quick
[Music]
and that's the second one turn off and
remove key from ignition
unless you have any other key fobs of
course
okay and now you're safe to remove the
programmer from the OBD2
and there you and there you have it both
key fobs should be programmed
repeat procedure for all remotes that
are not properly working let's test them
out
how about that
there we go on a truck that has never
had key fobs in its life in almost a
decade now has working key fobs
and wow makes certainly makes a
difference whenever you got stuff in the
back seat and look at the cap of this
you're probably carrying things around
if you've got a crew cab you gotta
unlock your doors whenever you get out
and then you can get to your back seat
and then you have to reopen the front
door just to lock the whole truck again
this will Streamlight the process make
it a lot easier might enter for your
phone might interfere with your vehicle
might interfere with planes going across
the sky here we go we now got two keys
and two key fobs all functional for this
truck and I drove this truck from the
west coast to the east coast and it was
a significantly long trip without having
key fobs talk about a blast from the
past out in the old west
let's see oh there we go with the noise
I'll try to see what I can do about that
pull the key out lock these doors
there we go and I know I got the key
with me I should have locked it in the
truck I'm gonna just use the fob and see
if I can get in now
and I'm going to go straight to the back
seat because I haven't been able to do
that ever
how about that
we are in the truck
foreign
[Music]
brand fob is significantly lighter than
the GM I'm not sure of the quality
difference it seems to be functional and
I've installed the doorman on the
previous truck and that seemed to work
well I think the batteries are the same
too and that is installing a key fob on
your 2014 2015 or 2016 Silverado this
also works on the Yukons and Suburbans I
think there was one other on the list
hope you guys enjoyed it was a very
simple install very low cost a little
enhancement to your vehicle the
instructions in the back of the
programmer too in a wise individual once
said let there be key fobs or key free
onboards